are you sick of your life well there's
an app for that there is a new app
called stranger and it lets you live
through the life of a stranger is that
confusing let's look at a video
[Music]
alright we got a little info there but
now we've got some facts for you the app
tracks your path pulling related photos
from Foursquare Google Maps along the
way neither person has to actively do
anything I think this is the interesting
part and no locations are ever
specifically named so anonymity is
preserved at the end of the experiment
each person has one chance to send a
message to the other either to say
goodbye or to exchange contact
information so just to be clear about
what's going on here this is stuff
that's all being pulled from your phone
for twenty days so you're not actively
posting to it it's just basically
watching everything you're doing for 20
days part of me thinks this is cool part
of me thinks this is crazy you know we
went from like you know when Facebook
started you actually were friends with
the people that you were friends with
then you suddenly became friends with
people that were friends with your
friends now you're friends with people
you don't know and now you you're
friends with people you don't even give
a about so this is this just the
next natural step in whatever this whole
bone is doing to all of us I can't think
of a more useless application as someone
else Jimmy you know it's like all those
people who do past life regressions
turns out they're all kings
it's just that same thing you know what
you're you don't you ever think the
other person is connected to is a
dock worker in Russia
I mean oh there's a guy who's out loaded
a truck in eastern Poland let's look and
see what he's doing all day he's
drinking unloading and then going
to bed right so that's actually a great
point we have such short attention spans
what are the chances anyone could follow
through with 20 days of being somebody
else people yeah it was the Jimmy's
point that was literally the worst
commercial I've ever seen there were
five different times that were said
driving yeah yes yeah oh great that's
really old now he's walking it's like
where he is it's quiet there is he in an
elevator I mean a car I don't know it's
quiet if you would set an elevator there
probably be background music so he's
probably if it's car he's got to have as
well I don't know I got to figure this
thing out let's set up a message but
Jimmy couldn't this break down walls
between nations you could see how the
israelis could see how the palestinians
are living the russians could see how
the ukrainians really they could just
turn on the TV or go on the internet
read something this is this is
unbelievable
I if i give me something here this is
gonna go this is gonna be just as
unpopular as the hula hoop I donated
related well yeah I think that the the
the the beauty in it would be in the
specificity and they're bragging about
the lack of specificity like bar yeah
what I get to take naked pictures of you
but just black out your face right so
that I'll be on for that see what the
person but a one other person for twenty
days you're supposed to go you don't
have anything going on in your life I
don't have enough time to get to these
people I already know to return
their emails there you gonna be tracking
someone you don't even know is probably
boring that's why they signed up for
this thing
I don't think interesting people do this
this will fail and then it'll the six
weeks into its failure they'll be like
how do we put a dick pic component or
gets bought for three billion bucks and
then Facebook does nothing with there's
those there's a grinder and tinder and
all that I mean that that's gonna
are you kidding me Adam are you very
optimistic that Israeli in a Palestinian
to be like oh my god I'm at a security
checkpoint they're playing Tetris well I
thought maybe there was something here
but maybe maybe it's this is because I'm
a little younger than you getting here
oh look you were making SodaStream
bottles and then getting pelted with
rubber bullets alright it's not gonna
create these and I tried I tried okay
kill me
[Music]